[All] - Hi, We're the Try Guys.
- And today, we're learning about coding.
- To help us out.
- We're here with Girls Who Code.
(cheering)
(imitation robot beeps)
- Computers!
(electronic music)
- Programming!
- We're here with Girls Who Code,
awesome, young women who are
going to change the world.
- In middle school 74% of girls
express science, technology
as part of their interests,
but in high school
when they're choosing
colleges, only .4% of girls
choose computer science as their major.
- Girls Who Code is here
to change that, am I right?
(cheering)
Yes, okay!
- So each of us is going
to be paired up with
one of the Girls Who Code.
- Hi Casey, I'm Ned.
I may be a little rusty, but
I already know the basics.
Basic programming language that is.
- What's your name?
- Kemi.
- Hi Kemi, I'm Zach.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Let's do some super cool coding.
- This morning I had a lot of confidence,
I'm like, "I got this."
Now, I'm here, I'm back in
the classroom, I'm terrified.
- Hello Elika.
- Hi.
- Hello, girl genius.
- I wouldn't go that far.
- I'm Eugene, boy idiot.
I didn't play video games as a kid,
I wasn't very tech-oriented.
HTML is something, right?
[All] - Yes.
- Yeah, that stands for
'Hot Tamale Momma Likey.'
- I'm Keith.
- I'm Jazmin.
- Jazmin, nice to meet
you, let's build Yahoo.com.
We're gonna be all this, that, this.
I'm gonna make stuff, it's gonna be great.
We're doing lines of code.
- How did you get into coding?
- I've always been around
coding, and my mom's a doctor
so she really encouraged
me to get in this.
She found the program and
I signed up immediately.
- How did you get into coding?
- I didn't, I just...
- No, yes you did, you're here.
(laughing)
Yes, you did, you're into coding.
- So would you want to
program a video game?
- Actually for our final project,
my group and I, we actually.
- She's like, I already have.
(laughing)
- What is this program called?
- We're using the programming
language of Python,
- Python?
Hiss.
- And in Calico.
(laughing)
- Why is this a thing you do?
- You're just doing all the work yourself,
you're the creator.
- I like to be the creator.
- When the computers rise up,
will they be more lenient on coders
because you guys are creators?
- I hope.
- Alright, then I'mma
hang out with all y'all.
(laughing)
'Cause that will happen.
- What are we going to
be doing today, Kasey?
- You're going to try printing
the string "Hello world!"
- Hello world, hello world!
(laughing)
- It's the first thing coders have to code
and it's good luck.
- The function print will
print out what you want,
so it's basically like
printing, but without paper.
- Ah!
- So if you press that
green button right there.
- This is the tiniest button,
why did they not design a bigger button?
I'm 'bout to run this script.
(laughing)
Boom, hello world!
Nailed it!
- This is the computer talking to me?
- You know, you can proceed
however you like, Eugene.
- Okay.
- I want to get a giant face
in the sky that vomits cats
every time you press the space bar,
and I want the cats to just
bounce around and go, "Meow!"
Is that something we can do?
- In 15 minutes I'm not sure.
- "Hello Ned's Wife, I love you."
[All] - Awe.
- You want to make a variable.
- What's a variable?
- Sort of how in algebra,
there's variables.
- What's algebra?
- So I'm going to do my own.
If name is, "So Zach"
then you print, "Hey baby,
baby, how you look so fine?"
- My program is going
to start, "What up dog?"
- The variable will be, "Arianagrande."
- Sure!
- And the command is, "Licks donuts."
(laughing)
- What's your name?
"Eugene."
Yay!
(laughing)
It just printed Eugene a bunch of times.
- Let's try it, I'm good at coding.
What, are you kidding
me, what could be wrong?
- You forgot a colon.
- Colon, come on?
- Yeah, the colon.
- Peter you've got to
think about your colon
both in health and programming.
- Did I do that right?
- No.
- It didn't say anything to me.
- Eugene, it says, "Yas!"
[All] - Yas!
- Oh, raw input, you idiot!
You idiot!
- No you should put it afterwards.
- Ahh!
(clapping and laughing)
- I still don't understand
what we are doing.
- Zach
[All] - Hey baby, baby how you so fine!
- You look so fine, girl you blow my mind.
- "Who will run the world"
and then everyone goes
[All] - Girls.
- I thought someone said,
"Squirrels," I was like...
- How did I do?
[All] - Good.
- Good job!
(cheering and clapping)
- We did it, thank you for
teaching me how to code.
I did it, I did it!
(cheering and clapping)
- You can do it, don't let
anyone tell you you can't.
Okay, you got this.
[All] - Just do it!
(electronic music)
- You're saying that you can do more this?
- Yeah
- You actually make the cats vomit?
- Yeah.
- I'm not going to say you should make it,
but if you did make it we
would put it in the video
and it would go right now.
- Meow, meow, meow, meow!